Okay.
We live Amy Schumer.
Oh,
very funny today.
It was hilarious.
He killed it.
I think beyond expectations,
you destroyed really very funny.
He made me how well I was
howling laughing very hard,
like four or five times.
It really,
really very,
very funny.
And uh,
I'm excited that we pulled this off.
You know,
we,
we communicated online.
We haven't even met until today.
The wonderment of the Internet isn't
the Internet and fucking a gem.
Isn't that fantastic Brian?
He's a lovely,
it's really outrageous.
I mean,
I was introduced to you.
Like I said,
from the trolley,
she and rose like right away.
I said,
oh my God,
this chick's hilarious.
Well,
how great would she be on the podcast?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Tweets back and forth.
Shit happens.
I don't even know the exact order.
Bam.
Look who's here.
Amy Schumer,
who could crushed it?
Amy Schumer misleading.
What's The lady right here?
Dude?
If you ever come here
and move here for real,
we want to hook you up for the podcast.
You're perfect for this shit.
It would change everything if you want to,
if you want to do really well.
It's comedian,
it's the best tool.
Like we're immediately,
you're going to get a big jump
in the amount of people that,
that,
that come to your show.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
I think it's my,
um,
my hesitance maybe that because of that.
That's why you're funny.
It's really a problem.
Well,
we're people who like are super ambitious
and promoting themselves are often
terrible douche bags.
They have like,
uh,
there's a two,
there's two different mentalities.
Like there's a mentality
of like promotion,
which is like,
I'm amazing.
You're part of the team.
We're doing this together.
Team really well.
Like Dane Cook was,
I liked Danko.
He's a good dude.
But I remember when he had the super
finger get the fuck outta here,
man.
Finger super figured you'd
like sue fire everybody.
It became his thing.
Like so far I was like his tee shirt.
He got crazy.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know of a finger.
So that's a dramatic marketing move.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't have that in,
you know,
I was too naive to know
that I need that right now.
You don't need that,
but you can get a with
Jetta with boys with matches.
That was your thing.
Insurance say he could eat it.
Okay.
You guys,
I'm telling you if that
would be your opening move.
Get a whiff.
Boys.
If he just
get a whiff,
boys and two.
I like it.
I like what you're doing.
Is it a worse parent?
Like who?
I don't trust.
I don't think I just learned
once it gets to the Internet,
whatever.
Where I miss you guys that I
will never try that I will never,
sorry.
We're gonna do is we're going to get
a less talented comedian and feed them
lines that we can come up with and if
that's a great idea at them to infiltrate
and become your best friend.
It's your comedy.
This is a,
we're going to have a tactical approach.
She's a crusher.
You gotta be careful.
Lunesta.
Yeah.
It's very funny.
Young lady who was a friend of ours,
she's the only other girl that just squad,
which you just joined.
Didn't realize he joined
the desk and me forever.
Well,
it's a Fisheye Lens.
That's fine.
Not Flattering.
Look at his face.
Just to forget about all this jazz.
Concentrate on Brian.
Brian right there.
You guys had a relationship
with someone who's aging poorly,
but it is weird.
It's a weird lens,
but um,
you guys had a relationship
on the podcast.
It was very strange in the beginning.
He was trying to please
you and he's trying to
get a little weird with you.
I just don't understand New York.
He thinks that New York people like,
Geez,
he thinks New York people
are kind of Douchey.
No,
I don't like people that much.
So
everywhere sounds
won't travel with them.
The idea live in stacked
on top of each other.
Like a hundred stories.
It's kind of night.
Yeah.
It's not good for you.
What are the big apartment buildings?
I mean a hundred stores is like,
that's the empire state building,
right?
Yeah.
What is,
what is like a big high rise in New York?
Because it's 60 70 floors.
Did they have like 64 sir?
How nuts is that?
Each other like 40 right?
I don't know.
I live on the first floor.
I know I get there and a moist half awake.
I'm always drinking coffee,
trying to wake up for opie and Anthony,
and if you're dealing with
all that regretting them,
those guys are the shit that,
that,
those guys are like.
Every time you do that show,
it's like hanging out with some friends.
It's like,
it's like,
you know,
it's doesn't feel like a radio show.
No,
it doesn't feel like,
you know,
it feels like you're all just shooting
the shit and try and make each other
laugh.
You feel better about
myself because I'm like,
ah,
now I know I'm not the
worst person on earth.
Well,
you also feel good,
don't you?
Because like you're kind of in
with these guys and everyone's,
you know that you're a
part of that and they all,
I remember,
I mean,
I had been doing comedy for a long time
at the first time I came on the show and
I was like,
you know,
I think they're kind of
notoriously tough on people.
Then all of sudden I'm like,
Holy Shit,
I'm on the opiate Anthony's right?
Like this is,
you know,
and it's working.
Let's go,
well this is pretty fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
Cause you,
when you're a young comic and
there's any established radio show,
whether it's Howard stern or you know any,
anyone where it's like,
you know,
like Holy Shit,
like this is like a,
a big,
like I did,
uh,
there was a guy and I'm mark Parenteau
was like big and WBCN in Boston and I did
his radio show once and I was like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe him doing his radio show.
Listen to this radio show when I was
a kid and I went to be on it live.
Yeah.
That's how I,
when I was for me.
Yeah.
Anytime.
You're like,
you're on.
Like if you,
you friends with Patrice and if you sit
in there with Patrice and you and him
and you know there's
Lucy Kay and Bobby Kelly.
Everybody's just shooting the shit.
Jimmy Norton.
It's like what a crazy little roundtable.
What a fun way to do a radio show.
Yeah.
You're making me grateful.
Oh,
you shouldn't be.
No,
I do.
I appreciate when we did Vegas with them.
How fucking fun was that?
It was fucking great.
You know,
that was really the only
time I got the hung out with.
I got to hang out with Patrice.
I didn't know Patrice that well.
You know,
I knew of him,
you know,
and when I met him I would
say hi to him and you know,
but we really,
the first time we really hung
out and talked was in Vegas,
was for that big,
oh it ain't show.
I got to hang out with him.
Talks about all kinds of shit.
Who got booed?
Not that one.
I know one that was the
Vegas one was a happy one.
It was fun.
While I flip,
I like to think of did
another one they would ask me,
they would totally ask you,
but the crowds were monsters.
I opened for Norton for a long time
in the road and it's different though.
These crowds are awesome.
But the ONA crowds,
there was savages,
savages,
crossover for sure.
But there's a lot of dudes that
would try to make guys fail.
I might eat shit there,
but I would like to risk it.
Did you see the bill burr video
bill burrs a monster?
Yeah.
If you don't know what it is folks,
check out bill bird.
This is Philadelphia.
They went on and booed dom.
I rera who for guys like me.
Dot.
My rare it's,
you know,
not just a friend of mine,
he's a Philly staple and uh,
he's a great standup comedian
and they were so mean.
They booed him like right from the star.
I just,
cause he doesn't do ONA that much.
I mean why did they boons it wasn't valid
for whatever reason they booed dom Irrera
and so bill burr was so incensed by
this.
He went up and just shit all over
Philly cause his whole act 10 minutes,
10 minutes.
You've got some of the best
boxes to have a commodity here.
Who Do you fucking love?
A white guy from a movie.
It was not real.
They thought rocky.
Oh was genius.
It was genius.
It's so good.
It's a,
it's one of the things that,
so that was the ona crowd savages,
crazy wildness.
Amy Schumer.
We want to thank you for being on the
podcast and people want to follow me on
Twitter.
It's Amy,
Yeah,
you gotta go cause that's
some other bitch and I grow.
Need to change.
Why you frightened my you pretending
you Amy Schumer follow Amy.
Twitter is hilarious.
Go see your life.
All right.
Later bitches.
Hello world or in Tokyo when you're a
bad motherfucker like Kyle Kingsbury,
you could rock a multicolored
better fanny pack.
See I'm not at that level.
I got to stick with the plain black fanny
pack and hope that it kind of fades in
the background.
This motherfucker shows up for the
weigh ins at a hot pink one hit.
Had a hot pink fanny pack
wants to the way is amazing.
Can you have one with like sequins
on it and she just rainbow sequence.
I know.
That's what people keep telling me this.
He looks like he's been
hanging out with me.
This is Anthony Giordano.
He's the guy who directed my a spike TV
comedy special and the next one and the
next one from Atlanta.
My Eyes Barbecue.
The
barbecue.
How high does he look?
Dude,
you look fucking high.
You look like you couldn't get any higher.
If you are high as kitty right now,
you were in a car with me
and it costs Bolus over.
I'd say pretend you're asleep.
My eyes are red or all their bread.
They're swollen and puffy.
Come on.
Are you?
Hi Him.
I'm not at all.
I will tell you Anthony,
I just do me a favor and turn right.
Just Paul and me.
Some of that shit right now.
Tell you,
show you what it's.
Go say
hi,
I'm Joe Susa.
Nice.
Awesome.
What about freaks out of the Internet?
Because this thing is
this thing run some late.
Some guy tried to tell me on Twitter,
like I was saying that
the pride lady was okay.
I said she was really good,
but she's not Bruce buffer.
I prefer Bruce Buffer.
And the guy's like,
are you fucking crazy?
The Pri Lady,
I got two words for you,
but for three 16 that's it.
It's the end of the conversation.
You're the only one who would
do that crazy private lady.
She might go vine.
It's Kinda cool.
It's Kinda cool,
but it's not as good as the buffer.
Do you know what I just
realized right now?
We don't need her cause I got you.
You should be up there and
we share in the guys with me.
Yeah,
I could do it.
Yeah.
Lenay is tweeting me to directly.
She's like,
we need to get together for drinks when
you're here we need to get together with
friends,
so fuck you and steal your power.
I just don't like the stuff
you say about the mom.
No,
I don't know that.
And I always want you to
know that if I say anything,
it's never out of disrespect.
I like you and are always
tell you there were,
since we hung out together,
when we do it inside,
I like you do I root for you if I ever
sang in front of me because I want you to
do that.
Hey,
I'd like you to,
if you know what I'm saying.
But it's just like,
it's just the outcome of like I
got these new fancy new UFC fans.
They don't know what the
fuck they talking about.
And when I meet them,
I'm tired of them saying that shit.
Did you say,
did they repeat a lot
of shit and they do it.
I respect that immensely.
Well,
all I'm doing is just trying
to get my thoughts on the shit.
I understand that it
fucks with you personally.
I can take criticism.
No,
but I don't want that.
What I'm trying to say is
I've never tried to do that.
It hurt my feelings.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I'm trying to fuck with you.
Honestly.
I'm gonna you.
Hey,
I can take criticism.
It didn't bother me.
Every time I meet one of these fans,
it's bringing shit up,
man.
Never had a case.
And you need to learn how to black kids.
You learn,
do you do you train?
UFC was like,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
it makes,
that turns me off to those fans,
maybe not even wanna talk to him.
So once I just walk
away or cussed them out,
I know that's a problem with the Internet
and the problem with the accessibility
that you even run it to
a certain amount of shit.
I know we do this the problem.
That's where I'm at.
Then I figured,
you know what I'm saying?
They didn't start to shift to a,
came here,
listen,
listen and stuff.
You say,
I don't say you got your job,
dude.
You know what I'm saying?
I can honestly say that I'm wrong for
even going in San and intermediate,
but when I did the interview or yeah,
I must've just seen some shit.
That's how I work.
I must've just saying some shit.
I just heard some shit right before I
did the interview and that's how I work
because I don't remember what I said now.
It doesn't matter.
You know?
I just want you to know that it's
never disrespectful and if I,
if it never on my phone
number saying anything,
just we need to do.
All right.
Rolling.
Don't worry about it.
Correct.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh
[inaudible] [inaudible]
be real nice gentleman
to send out the podcast.
It was fun,
man.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for,
we freaked everybody out.
We've got scared about animals.
It was awesome.
Especially talking about scary shit.
It's something fun about being high,
talking about things they can fuck
you up in another part of the world.
I don't know what it is,
but it's so compelling,
but it's good to know
what gets stuck you up.
It is hard to sit there and go there.
Avoid the shit.
Yeah,
don't get,
get out of your car.
State me your fucking car man.
And there's birds that will kill you.
Okay.
This fucking crazy birds in
Australia that will jack you.
They run up to people on the beach
and they check him occasionally.
Talk that crazy.
Fuck that.
I'm not going to the beach.
Is that going?
Is that rolling?
Oh,
hey,
we're great for 10 minutes.
This is,
we do a post,
uh,
post podcasts.
Video blogs.
Yeah.
We have a lot of people put videos.
That's cool.
At one more way to reach people,
man.
Underneath it all.
I mean,
you're talking to him and live.
You talking to him here to
tweeting and we're doing this.
What,
what is it?
I mean obviously if you were Santorum,
you would just want people to kill
abortion doctors and such as tick.
That's what he wants.
One scarves to sergeant star.
I would let people do that.
That's what he wants.
He wants you think that's what's
underneath it all starts with stuff.
Just took his [inaudible] pretty sure
whenever guys trying to stop gay things,
he's usually gay.
Yes.
It's probably a little bit,
maybe it's 10% but if you're allowing
gay things then you're gay or straight.
If you're promoting gay
things should definitely do,
can't win out of the closet.
When you're in the closet.
You,
you try to stop Caifanes
we've got to stop this.
Well that's why I loved um,
uh,
what's her name's husbands as
she was running for a couple of,
yeah.
Oh,
Christine.
Yeah.
What's the name?
Oh,
Donal.
Christine O'Donnell.
No,
no,
no.
That's the Senate Delaware.
Michelle Buck.
Michele.
Bob.
Her husband was doing like a,
a a learn how to not be gay thing and
then you see him dancing and shit.
Ba is greatest.
I just wanted her to become president
because what a story that was big and
awesome.
She kind of just stopped.
Right?
She got trounced.
I mean she was getting no numbers and so
she went back to Texas and she endorsed
Mitt Romney
but getting back to a gay,
what's the gay is thing like if you
had to think in your life that was,
what was the moment you are
the gayest I guess Jujitsu.
Yeah,
essentially.
And your,
your your fucking underwear but cop
on she ever get any?
No.
Anybody else ever get any,
Ooh,
that would be a bump.
That would make it a real fight.
That would instantly transition to
like your story that you told them the
podcasts about going over the rave scene
seems the girl and he had a bone or the
whole time,
sorry.
Sorry.
I think I did that with Jujitsu.
That would be a real problem though.
That should be a sport is two guys
wrestling and one of them has to get an
erection to start the fight.
That guy could attack first and you
can only defend until you got your dick
hard.
That might be the gayest
thing I've ever done.
It's the gas thing ever.
That might be the greatest
thing I ever thought up.
Gay and aggressive and dominant.
What's the closest you ever came to?
What will be considered date rape?
Like with a girl like that?
I did not scan of gay.
Yeah.
I guess when you're young and
the girl says no and you keep,
you keep grabbing her hand and
put it on your tenure and yeah,
I mean that's essentially she's saying
no and you're still trying to put her
hand on your deck.
Yeah,
but you never know when they go.
Okay.
Now
let's talk a lot about rape.
I noticed what were around you
were on you or rape instincts kick in.
He had,
there's something about you that,
I'm not getting them out of rapists but
like all I want to do is fucking ray
radio in the ass.
I Dunno.
Maybe it's a Boston thing.
Can you grab that?
Still go with this.
I'm not on,
that would be the gayest
thing you've ever done.
I thought you bought that for your girl.
You didn't buy it for her.
He bought for a joke for
somebody not cool dildo.
They're always black cause
that's what everybody wants.
They want,
they want Reggie Bush.
She,
is that what it was to me on ports.
I know female at once.
You can buy a fleshlight that that's
like a women's like a porn stars vagina.
They do they have that from your point?
Yes.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah they have that.
Uh,
I bet they have a for
dudes bottles cause I know,
I bet they do.
Gay dudes.
How'd you like to be the guy that's
going to measure and sculpted?
I wouldn't like to be that guy.
That would be the gang.
It's the electric rate.
Well I want to,
I feel like at some points in the
interview I started interviewing you and I
apologize.
It was like a conversation.
It wasn't even an envelope and there were
some things I just wanted to ask you.
Open ended existential things because uh,
I think that you have a
unique perspectives on things.
And so I was curious about some of them,
like gun control we were talking about
earlier and I was always for gun control.
And a couple of weeks ago
I completely flipped sides.
And now I don't think that
everyone should have a gun,
but I just can't.
I'm a,
I'm a facts guy and I looked at all
the numbers and it's very hard to
legitimately say that we need to
have gun control.
Well,
there should be some control
or some criminal shouldn't
be allowed to have guns.
And I agree it shouldn't be,
you shouldn't be screenings.
You know,
there should be that,
that I agree with all that stuff.
But what I don't agree with is the idea
that we live in some sort of a Utopian
society where violence has been cured
and you don't need to protect yourself.
That's crazy.
If cops have guns,
people should have guns.
There's a reason why the
compounds that we've got,
the cop asked to have a
gun to protect society.
Well,
one of the cops aren't there.
you better have a fucking gun.
You should have a gun.
You shouldn't use it if
you don't have to use it.
But would they say brandishing it,
um,
prevents like 90 something percent of
crimes from happening and then eventually
you don't even have to brand.
It should because people have
to wonder if you have one.
Yeah,
I guess I'm not suddenly
like I'm not encouraging it.
It's just,
it was fucking mind opening to have
held a belief for so many years and then
realize that it was the
foundation of it was off.
It's a core tenant
of left wing thinking that you're
supposed to get the guns or make them as
restrictive as possible.
People don't need guns.
Guns cause problems.
It's like that's,
you know,
there's certain thinking like
abortion should be legal.
Women has a right to choose and you know
when you bring it home you should be
able to shoot the,
maybe it's a fetus,
you bring it up to them.
Like what's really going on when you're
saying the right to choose to choose to
suck that baby out with
the vacuum and kill it.
No,
no.
Well yes,
sort of.
I mean at what point in time is it a baby?
Three months.
At four months they started
looking like things.
Yeah.
And it's,
it is illegal then or it's not legal
that it's legal then it's a ball of mush.
Yeah.
When it comes to looking like a baby,
then it's not like,
but no one wants to even
have that discussion.
Now.
The cat's had a joke.
He goes,
I believe that human life begins
after the Second Cup of coffee,
but the best is the Republicans ago.
All right,
here's the caveat.
Uh,
no abortion,
except in the case of rape and incest.
Okay?
So what you're saying is that's a
human life and it's being murdered,
but it's okay to murder it if
somebody who raped somebody.
Well,
if you don't live for,
it's not
Rick Santorum says that you
should celebrate the rate
baby because it's a gift
from God.
How do you celebrate?
Do you have what you'd even have
a board like every birthday,
happy birthday to you.
Gift from God.
So rape baby.
Wow,
you're like a beautiful baby.
I mean the,
yeah,
that guy's a rapist.
And every time you see him,
you have to think about what my baby
looks just like this means help me down
Saturday to me.
But he said that you should.
What do you believe?
Should abortion be legal?
I don't believe I have the right to tell
you what to do with a bunch of cells in
your body and that we'd have to decide
at what point in time does that become a
life?
And it was,
it isn't an early detection issue
cause it was an early detection issue.
I mean how much different is it to
have a birth control pill that tricks
chemically the body into the sperm
comes in and tries to do its job,
but there's nothing there because the
body thinks that it's already pregnant.
How much different is that
than killing two cells?
The birth control pill actually allow
a sperm attach and then it goes right.
No birth control pill
is essentially hormones.
The trick the woman's body into
thinking that it's already pregnant.
So no sperm ever attaches
to it to an over,
maybe it's not a hundred
percent effective.
The way it works is the women can't get
pregnant while they're already pregnant.
So it's setting the hormones that
leapt up to about another story with,
yeah,
yeah.
Well that's why it really
fucks with their whole system,
you know?
Right.
It's like you should just be a way,
I mean the diaphragm
is a bad example of it,
but diaphragm kind of thing where it
just goes in when you're in a period of
your life where you're not going to
have babies and it comes off when you're
ready and if you can't and it should be
cheap and it should be paid for by the
government function.
Well,
because they used to
make them out of metal,
I UDS or metal and now they make
them out of some kind of thing
or metal and your pussy
just to stop loads.
I know.
Yeah,
it was a spring.
Right,
but isn't that,
I mean,
isn't that a as close to a perfect
solution as we can get has just on off.
It's an off switch
I guess.
Yeah.
But then like what if society
falls apart and you know,
you live in the woods and you really
want to have babies now because society
might die off and you've got the slide,
you d stuffed up your pussy and
there's no doctors available.
A couple sticks,
pull it out with some tweezers.
How'd it get in there?
I didn't even look around.
Well,
you get little circles.
This is what we're going to,
I'm going to tie a rope
to it and the other,
but it's going to put on a horse should
have got off and he's got a rug and it
pull the ideas
and on that note can doors around
or you can go to race track.
Hey Fella,
I went to bed and Suzanne was a video.
You don't even know what the fuck is up.
It should have happened.
Bam.
Nowhere.
We just got done doing the podcast
and it was really fucking fun.
Is that a bad example?
That's the reality.
Both
true and real
court.
Ben,
we just got done doing the podcast the
first time anybody's ever performed songs
on the podcast and that right Brian?
It's pretty bad ass.
Pretty fucking cool.
That's a good time.
We had a great time.
We hit a stride to,
yeah,
it was really fun in 45 minutes.
Then I think runaway,
well,
I got a lot of positive uh,
Twitter responses or super excited about
the insecure.
It's good.
It's good to have the balance.
Most of them are insecure
cause he's in subscribes.
Yeah.
A little bit terrified of being one that
you don't like.
Female voices.
What in what way?
Being a pussy.
But then now I've accepted
it and I enjoy it.
Did you enjoy being a pussy or excepted
accepted people that call you a pussy?
You're assholes.
You know what it is.
But that's true.
You know.
But the problem is sometimes you know,
you get a
resent non pussies and
that's really not fair.
You know,
this sort of reverse
type of discrimination
except him off reverse
discrimination sticks.
Agency did.
You can be a bad ass.
We need you.
Yeah.
That was the yellow belt for a minute.
It's when you're a little kid.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was spread the light.
Oh and karate.
If you took my my shirt there I'd go,
oh you know how to do it.
Probably take your hand.
Wow.
Like a panther edit out.
Um,
but you started doing it recently,
right?
You started taking Jujitsu?
I did.
A little while ago.
I got the shrimp out.
I've got a couple of them.
Don't worry.
Oh No.
If you know other than the shrimp out,
you'd have to test me
in a combat situation.
I'd rather know I can do a
full Nelson and I heard that,
but apparently I heard that
was illegal in wrestling.
I know how to chill.
I'm serious.
I know.
The one thing,
I think it's illegal in Eritrea
that it's a rear naked choke,
but if you give it like that on the head,
actually us more leverage.
If you go like karate chop.
Yeah,
as you,
as you get it underneath the neck,
under the arms.
This one right here was this way
and then this one lyric there,
grab your bicep like this and then you
karate chop the back of his head like
this.
We're not,
that's where the pressure comes in,
but I feel like I,
my Chin tell you really,
you really go,
yeah,
he's got his Chin Tuck.
You want to get under that,
but if you've got a really good squeeze,
you can take him from there.
Let me tell you something.
Well,
okay,
I see.
That was an easy,
it doesn't always work.
See a lot of these techniques
that take years to train.
Totally.
Maybe look on cool.
I can,
you want me to shine for the children?
I think you kind of shine honey,
honey band.
Follow them on Twitter.
It's honey honey band on Twitter at
one whole gigantic word and their honey
honey,
ban.com not to be confused with honey.
honey.com which is a sad
sight for shitty parenting
is the Joe Rogan experience
12th of never know.
Put it in your calendar.
I didn't even,
Oh God,
I'm Austin.
Yeah.